This strange expression appeared in our equation for heat conduction along the wire.
Now, we look into its mathematical meaning.
The scary name for this topic is central difference formulas for derivatives.
This is about determining the derivative, that means the slope of the tangent of functions
that are based on empirical data, measurements,
and now your approach to determine the slope of this function at this point
would be to look a little further to the right, determine another point of that function there,
and then connect this point to our original point and you can see that this doesn't really work well
but we want to determine the derivative of our function namely the slope of the tangent.
The simple trick is to go a little to the left and a little to the right.
Determine the points of the function, left and right and then connect these.
To be clear, this works far better. Now we can write down some equations.
That's Δx stand for the total distance from left to right. Δ always is denoting the difference.
The estimate for the slope would be what we gain in height divided by how far we went to the right.
The denominator is simple, Δx is how far we went to the right. The numerator is a little more complex.
It's the difference of this value of the function minus that value of the function.
That's what we are gaining in height, so it's our function on the right-hand side, f(x₀ + Δx/2)
from x₀, we are moving by half of this distance to the right
plus Δx/2 minus the value of the function on the left-hand side f(x₀ -Δx/2)
that go into the left by half of the distance minus.
Now you can get an idea about why this is called central difference.
Obviously, it's a difference and the difference is centered at x₀.
we're moving as much to the right as we're moving to the left.
Now, we're going to apply the same formula to the second derivative.
The rate of change of the rate of change, and think acceleration.
We simply use this formula not for the original function, but for its derivative.
You replace f by f' wherever you find an f. So this f becomes an f'.
This f becomes an f' and this f becomes an f'. Prime, the second derivative.
But now we can use our original formula for these derivatives. This is going to get a little long.
When estimating this first derivative, we get an expression with denominator Δx
and in the numerator, we got the following.
We are moving to the right by Δx/2, so we're ending with f(x₀+Δx).
We are moving one further Δx/2 to the right minus we are moving Δx/2 to the left
which means this is f(x₀) and now for this derivative.
We are moving by Δx/2 to the right minus Δx/2 + Δx/2, canceled.
So this becomes f(x₀) minus now we have to move by Δx/2 to the left which becomes f(x₀ - Δx)/Δx.
Let's now collect what we have found in total, we are dividing by (Δx)²
and in the numerator, we've got plus the value one step to the left plus the value one step to the right
minus twice the value at our original position.
So what originally appeared in our equation,
T7 + T9 -2(T8) is 1 mm² plus the second derivative of the distribution of the temperature.